hey 42 here isn't it incredible how a
single speech has the power to change
the world in 1588 king philip ii
launched an ambitious invasion of
England with the mighty Spanish Armada
as his primary weapon as many as a
hundred and sixty warships set sail
towards England shores with the goal of
the froning the Protestant Queen
Elizabeth the first as English sailors
and soldiers assembled as a camp at
Tilbury in Essex ready to take on their
greatest ever foe they were surprised
when their Queen came riding into the
middle of the camp wearing a velvet
dress with a steel breastplate on top
showing that this woman this Queen of
England was ready to fight beside them
to defend her country if needed
Elizabeth was a female Queen in an age
when women were thought to be less
intelligent than men and the man was
still legally allowed to beat his wife
to a bloody pulp yet she had the
self-confidence to deliver a speech that
has gone down in history beside the
Great's I am come amongst you as you see
at this time not for my recreation and
Dysport
but being resolved in the missin heat of
the battle to live and die amongst you
all to lay down for my god and for my
kingdom on my people my honour and my
blood even in the dust I know I have the
body of a weak and feeble woman but I
have the heart and stomach of a king and
a king of England too and think foul
scorn at Parma or Spain or any Prince of
Europe should dare to invade the borders
of my realm it can't be proven that the
English defended that country against
the Spanish any better as a result of
this speech but it certainly helped
inspire confidence in thousands of
soldiers and they went on to enjoy one
of England's greatest ever military
victories the Spanish were defeated
decisively and most of the mighty Armada
was reduced to ruins and was forced to
shipwreck along the coast of Ireland
this victory was the turning point in
modern history that ended Spain's reign
as global superpower
and gave way for England to rule waves
and every corner of the earth in the
coming centuries although despite its
effectiveness
Elizabeth's speech also included the
following line I know already for your
forward nurse you have to serve through
awards and crowns and we do assure you
in the word of a prince they shall be
duly paid you which was a total lie
many the English soldiers were never
paid for their service and left to deal
with their own mortal wounds in a ditch
so a great speech doesn't even have to
be truthful all that need achieve is to
inspire confidence in of us and you can
do great things with a few well-chosen
words so them how come so many of us are
absolutely terrified of public speaking
even in front of small groups of friends
or family and what can you do to fix it
and become a public speaking god I'll
let you into a little secret everyone is
scared of public speaking your teacher
your doctor Academy award-winning actors
that prime minister and yes the
President of the United States the
chemistry that gives us butterflies and
stage fright before speaking is so baked
into the human mind that nobody can
entirely erase it from their psyche some
have reported their fear of public
speaking to be worse than their fear of
death but what is that chemistry that
makes every one of us feel this way a
fear of public speaking is known as
glossophobia from the Greek glossa
meaning tongue when you deliver a speech
there is always a fear that you will be
rejected by the audience they may laugh
at you heckle you
or even boo you are putting yourself
into a very risky and vulnerable
situation at least that's how your brain
views it consciously you may know that
nothing that seriously bad could happen
by getting up on that stage but
subconsciously your brain will sense the
potential danger because truthfully
there is always a small risk of
embarrassment or even danger when public
speaking you may say something to a
then the crowd and risk public ridicule
and the more public speaking you do the
greater the risk every single word the
president says is scrutinized and with
every speech he risks impeachment or
more likely a severe dip in polling
figures so whether you want it or not
your brain reacts to this danger by
engaging the flight-or-fight response
yes that's all frustrating chess not
this is controlled and initiated by a
very primitive part of the brain called
the limbic system specifically in the
amygdala this system evolved millions of
years ago to detect and react to threats
in the wild is so primitive and
hardwired into the deepest parts of our
brains that we can't simply turn it off
by gently telling it it's okay this
crowd of people won't eat me alive
just minutes before you are due to speak
the limbic system will release
epinephrine and norepinephrine in your
system this increases your awareness and
focus but these chemicals will also
induce a nervous system response that
tenses your muscles increases your heart
rate and breathing and dilate your
pupils your neck and face will blush red
as the blood surges to every corner of
your body in preparation for a fight and
your digestive system stops which causes
your mouth to stop producing saliva and
go really dry which is exactly what you
need before protecting a speech to an
auditorium on one hand it's a real shame
that your body inflicts you with this on
avoidable biological response because
the consequences of spending your entire
life avoiding public speaking or
debilitating you could be actively
avoiding opportunities to get a
promotion make more money or inspire
others not to mention the risk of
missing out on that's amazing feeling of
immense self satisfaction when you
perfectly deliver a speech and you walk
away knowing you struck a deep chord
with the audience so how can you fix
your fear of public speaking well for a
start you can't fix it for reasons I
just mentioned your fear of public
speaking is a fixed buy
logical response that no amount of
practice or experience can overcome
furthermore you wouldn't want to remove
your anxiety your body's response to
public speaking actually helps you it
focuses your mind and prepares your body
for the challenge ahead without this
vital biological response you wouldn't
be able to perform anywhere near as well
as you caught when you are in the
spotlight even if you were super
confident but you can certainly do some
things to manage your fear and learn to
work with your body instead of letting
it hold you back one of the most
important skills you can learn is
self-confidence it doesn't matter who
you are how old you are it doesn't
matter if you have a speech impediment
or you're not a native English speaker
you can deliver a memorable and
impactful speech you must learn to
believe 110 percent in yourself and what
you have to say 90% of what politicians
say is but they have such
immense self-confidence that they don't
care because they believe in it
themselves and that's all that matters
at least to win the people over tell
yourself over and over again that you
can't fail imagine you're going through
a job interview but you already have the
job gaining self-confidence is much
easier said than done but do you know
what you can do to help achieve it
practice I know practice is the answer
to everything
but it really is the only way you can
wrest control of your fear of public
speaking obviously you need to know the
words of your speech like you know your
own name there's no point in even
attempting a speech that isn't burned
into your memory you're setting yourself
up to fail and you're only giving
yourself another unnecessary reason to
be nervous but learning the words to
your speech is only the beginning of
effective practice there are a few
skills that once you've mastered even if
you're only delivering the speech to
your sofa will give you the
self-confidence to deliver that speech
to anyone the first is proper pacing
practice slowing yourself down
way down where most people especially
nervous people deliver a speech for the
first time they really soft their tongue
like it's leaving a bad taste in their
mouth speaking as fast as possible to
hopefully get the ordeal over with
sooner but not only does this scream
anxious amateur to the audience but they
will also completely zone out to not
listen to a single word you're saying
imagine if Martin Luther King jr. spoke
like this so even though we face the
difficulties of today and tomorrow I
still have a dream it is a dream deeply
rooted in the American dream
yeah the Lincoln Memorial grounds would
have cleared out faster than you could
say Mississippi so slow right down and
that a few pauses now Annette they give
you a chance to compose yourself and
take a breath and the well-timed pause
doesn't bore the audience
quite the opposite it holds their
attention and intrigues them as to what
you're going to say next also work on
your body language though Pollin going
on to state of your hands in your
pockets instead make your chest as big
and wide this not only makes you see
more confidence and it gives you more
authority but it actually gives you more
self-confidence why do you think every
politician adopts such ridiculous power
pose which makes them look like they
were about to do something else on the
stage
some argue that by adopting this stance
it makes them feel and more confidence
and thus deliver a better speech the
science is still on shore on whether
this power pose actually increases
confidence levels but at the end of the
day it's a personal thing if it works
for you it makes you feel strong then
you spread those legs goddamnit but I
would just like to make a small caveat
to all of this I still think that the
most important thing is to just be
yourself there's no point in focusing on
how far apart your feet are and what
your hands are doing if your personality
isn't coming through to the audience
because at the end of the day and that's
what will make your speech special and
unique you but don't just practice these
techniques in your bedroom the biggest
improvement in your public speaking
confidence and skills will come when you
start delivering speeches to strangers a
few visits to it
Toastmasters or of a public speaking
group can transform you from a shaking
leaf to a confident orator but if after
endless rehearsing and practice you
still can't bring yourself to stand up
in front of hundreds or thousands of
people and speak aloud then try getting
pissed you may think that's an
irresponsible piece of advice but I beg
to differ
we're out Garland's is your system it
blocks communication between your
amygdala the park we talked about
earlier responsible for the
fight-or-flight and your prefrontal
cortex when these two can no longer
communicate your brain stops appraising
its own actions in other words it's
unable to tell itself that what you're
about to do is stupid and you may come
to harm on alcohol your brain
experiences less fear and less shame and
the fight or flight response is severely
dampened that's why people feel
invincible when drunk and generally more
confidence and douche stupid things now
I'm not advocating going onstage and
delivering an important speech more
Trollied than an actual trolley because
you're going to seriously embarrass
yourself if you drink too much
you'll definitely forget your speech and
you won't be able to stand up straight
never mind speak straight but if having
just a couple of small glasses of wine
before an important speech helps to
remove that cliff edge of fear for you
and it is the difference between you
delivering a confident speech or
climbing got halfway through and
breaking down in tears then I say go for
it
after all relying on a bit of alcohol to
speak publicly every few months doesn't
make you an alcoholic you're just using
a readily available tool to control and
dampen your body's biological response
you're not alone a significant amounts
of famous actors got a little or a lot
drunk before performing some of
Hollywood's most memorable scenes and
one day who knows you may feel confident
enough to speak sober well that was some
terribly responsible advice but do you
know what isn't terrible and is
definitely not irresponsible
Skillshare Skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
classes in writing business public
speaking and more
Premium Membership gives you unlimited
access to high-quality classes
on most no topics so you could improve
your skills unlock new opportunities and
just do the work you love if you're
ready to take your public speaking and
presentation skills to the next level
then I highly recommend the Skillshare
course presentation essentials how to
share ideas that inspire action skill
share is really affordable an annual
subscription is less than ten dollars a
month
and since Gil sure has sponsored this
video anyone can get two free months to
try out risk-free simply by clicking my
unique promo link in the description
thank you for watching and thanks again
to Skillshare for sponsoring this video
be sure to check them out using the link
below